so it seems that israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
is coming towards the end possibly of
his political reign in power
12 years of power that means perhaps
the end of the banner showing us how
close iran
is to acquiring a nuclear weapon a red
line should be drawn
right here
or benjamin netanyahu's old dvd stash
another 55 000 files on 180
cds he's a large dude player sorry
i mean i mean the iranian nuclear files
which
didn't really mean anything is it ready
for the hood sorry is it ready for the
hood but more importantly netanyahu is
not going down without a fight to
protect israel from what he calls a
left-wing government
which is composed of hard right-wingers
who are even further to the right than
him like naftali bennett for instance
evigdor lieberman gideon
tsar and the list goes on and part of
beniman netanyahu's kicking and
screaming
is actually putting not just israel and
palestine on the verge of war but
also the region on a verge of all-out
warfare
we have seen since the ceasefire between
the armed groups in gaza
and israel that there has been constant
provocation by
israeli forces in jerusalem in the west
bank against palestinian citizens of
israel
and even operations which have been
pushing the buttons of the armed groups
in gaza
including blocking of the qatari aid
money which was to come in and help gaza
rebuild yes we have commissioned half a
billion us dollars
and most of that will be going for
rebuilding houses
we've even seen close allies of benjamin
netanyahu
like itamar ben gavir who is a member of
the knesset for
the far right wing atma yehudit party
who pledged that he would be at a far
right settler rally with groups that
wish to storm
al-aqsa mosque and netanyahu doesn't
seem to have taken
any issue with these provocative moves
attacks on demonstrators attacks on
innocent civilians in jerusalem and the
massive
arrest crackdown campaign on palestinian
citizens of israel
as any sort of problem despite the fact
that settler marches on al-aqsa mosque
and in the old city of jerusalem
and attacks on palestinians in jerusalem
is actually what triggered the reaction
from the gaza strip last time and
started this
massive round of fighting which lasted
for 11 days and has been labeled the 11
day war
on top of that as well benjamin
netanyahu has not stopped talking about
iran and has actually threatened iran
again and many people are saying perhaps
may even launch some sort of strike or
attack on iran
or iranian facilities which could end up
triggering an all-out war and
all of this for netanyahu would benefit
him greatly because it would delay the
process of the new coalition government
coming into power with of course naftali
bennett who is a far
right winger perhaps even further to the
right of netanyahu coming into power in
a power sharing agreement with yer lapid
and netanyahu has done everything in his
path
to make sure that even if this
government comes in that he can break it
up and he can divide the parties
so that netanyahu can still stay in
power and when we turn back to the issue
of jerusalem again
and the provocations there what we will
see is that not only the armed groups in
gaza
are swearing that they will get involved
and that they will perhaps launch
strikes on israel but also even said
nasrallah who is the secretary general
of lebanese hezbollah has vowed that
attacks on
al-aqsa mosque the third holiest site to
muslims will
trigger perhaps an all-out regional war
so netanyahu
in order to save what he calls a
right-wing government which he can't
form
from being replaced by a government
which has a lot of
figures who are further to the right
than him is perhaps looking to drag
the entire region into war over his own
power
yet if this regional war does kick off
and there is
any sort of fighting between the
palestinian armed groups and the israeli
military
most likely what we're gonna hear from
the mainstream press is
the story starts with hamas rocket fire
or
iran's aggression but in this case it is
so incredibly clear
that the provocations have been
specifically started by benjamin
netanyahu to protect his own political
life